here and uh we're going to have
something we're going to have a very
special year next year i think is going
to be
more successful than it was last year we
had the best year we've ever had last
year
and i think we're going to be right in
that category for next year so that's
very successful
no i'm not thinking about concession
speech or acceptance speech yet
uh hopefully we'll be only doing one of
those two and you know
winning is easy losing is never easy
not for me it's not uh but i think we
have when we
when you see rallies the likes of which
in the history of this country probably
in the history of the world nobody's
ever seen before
um there's a tremendous love going on in
this country and there's really a
tremendous unity
there's a tremendous unity nobody's ever
seen that where you take
an airport and the airport's not big
enough to hold the crowds
nobody's ever seen a thing like that and
our opposition as you know would
have a few people sitting in circles and
that's okay that's not
abnormal that's not abnormal actually i
mean that's the way it is but
we would get crowds of 50 000 people 45
000 people more
nobody's ever seen anything like that so
it was an honor they're great people
these are people that they appreciate
what we did
and they also remember before i got
there and before we all got there this
group has been with me a lot of them are
very young but they've been with me
many of them for a long time right a
long time
and i just wanna i really came here to
thank you all and then i'm gonna say
and get immediately back to work
[Applause]
[Applause]
well we spent a lot of time in
pennsylvania it's always been
a very good place for me i went to
college there it's always been good
i think pennsylvania is very important
florida is very important obviously
a lot of people talked about texas and
texas is
we we will have a tremendous victory
there based on you know
everything that you see this is no
longer polls this is now we're looking
at what's happening
tremendous it'll be a tremendous victory
in texas uh i'm hearing we're doing
tremendously well in arizona
i think we're doing well all over yeah
what do you think we'll do
well i think you'll know possibly
tonight depending on the extent of
a victory i think you could know tonight
i think the ruling on pennsylvania was
an unfortunate one by the supreme court
because i think we should know
what happens on the night let people put
their ballots in earlier
but you have to have you have to have
numbers you can't have these things
delayed for
many days and maybe weeks you can't do
that the whole world is waiting this
country is waiting but
the whole world is waiting and a lot of
shenanigans a lot of bad things happen
with ballots when you
say oh let's devote days and days and
all of a sudden the ballot count changes
and
you take a look at philadelphia the
history of philadelphia politics
no i don't put people on their honor
code i don't think it's right and i
think it's a very dangerous thing that
they've done with that decision
and maybe their wisdom will change that
decision or
maybe we'll go back and give them a
right to change it
but that's a terrible it's a very
dangerous decision for this country
what they did with pennsylvania and some
others
also you have to have a date and the
date
happens to be november 3rd and we should
be entitled to know who won
on november 3rd and if somebody comes
along and puts a ballot in
way late they shouldn't be they should
put the ballot in earlier there's no
reason why they can't put the ballot in
two weeks earlier or one week earlier
i think it's a very dangerous decision
for our country in many ways dangerous
in many ways
well i may i mean we're going to have to
see we have a big night planned we're
going to have a very big night
i just think we're going to have a
tremendous i think we're going to have
it look i'm looking
right now i'm looking at different
locations
and we're seeing lines of people and
they're wearing a lot of
red material including hats but no i'm
we're
in certain areas that would be trump
areas we're seeing lines of people that
are
extended for miles you're seeing it too
i mean you don't
have to say you but you're seeing it too
so i think we're going to have a great
night
but it's politics and its elections and
you never know i can say that
uh texas arizona a few of them are
looking really very very strong florida
looking very very strong they spent
hundreds of millions of dollars in
florida
but the people of florida they know i
love them and they love me you know we
just have a
automatic bond yeah please especially
from seniors
no i don't think we're gonna have any
slippage i think we're gonna have look
my relationship to seniors i happen to
be a senior i don't want to say that too
loud and there's good
people that are averaging about 20 years
old but but
i don't think we're going to have
anything i think of anything we're going
to do very well i
i have seen and we have seen african
americans
way up and hispanic americans way up
and people have seen that and you know
i've said
with regard to african-american the
black
community i've done more than any other
president with the exception of abraham
lincoln
and sometimes i say with the possible
exception of abraham lincoln but
let's give him a lot of credit right but
i've done more than any other president
in the history of this country for
african-american
the black community and they understand
a criminal justice reform prison reform
historically black colleges and
universities you look at what we've done
opportunity zones with tim scott south
carolina is great
uh nobody's done what i've done
in terms of the african-american
community so
and they see it and they're tired of
being used by the democrats for a
hundred years i mean it's like been 100
years
so i think we're doing very well there
and i've heard we're doing very well
with the hispanic
the hispanic community
well you'll see that in the filings but
we had we had plenty of money i will
tell you we had plenty of money
and what i didn't do is call up wall
street and say send me 25 million
to the head of every firm i could have
done that i would have been the all-time
king of fundraising if i did that
but once you do that you can no longer
deal properly with them
you just can't so i didn't do that we
could have done that i could have raised
much more money i mean hillary clinton
spent much more money than i did
and in this case when they raised that
much money that means to me they're
making deals
and that can happen so thank you very
much we'll maybe see you later
have an exciting day and for you i just
appreciate everything you've all done
and we'll see you soon okay
[Applause]
my